Danke Herr Silberstein. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. November 2001.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 68 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 Meter.
Herr Silberstein, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwaden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich fühle mich seit ungefähr drei Wochen ziemlich krank.
Ich bin müde.
Ich bin erschöpft.
Ich habe wenig Appetit.
Ich habe auch Fieber.
Meistens abends bis 38,5.
Meistens abends?
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie das Fieber?
Ja, auch seit drei Wochen.
Okay.
Silber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 3. Mai 1992.
1992.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
60 Kilogramm.
Herr Nosken, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
Okay.
Am 16. September 1964.
Herr Nosken, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 74 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 Meter.
Okay.
Und wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 11. September 1969.
60. Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter und ich wiege zur Zeit 79 Kilo.
79 Kilo.
Frau Schmidt, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Was will ich tun?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 23. März 1954.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich kann Sie ganz schlecht verstehen, gerade im Moment.
Es ist ganz leise.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege noch 74 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 Meter.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle?
Ich wiege nur noch 74 Kilo.
74 Kilo.
Ich habe abgenommen.
Vielen Dank.
Und nachnahmes Ball, BO, doppel L.
Ich bin 44 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 25. März 1989.
1989.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege nur 1,79 Meter.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
32 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. Mai 1992.
Super.
Frau Heisangoth, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 Meter.
Ja, und 70.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
60 Kilo.
Und der Familienname, B A, umlaut, C K E R.
Wie der Bäcker, der die Gurte macht.
Okay, danke.
Frau Becker, ja?
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Becker?
Ich bin 58.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. August 1966.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Bitte, wie groß?
Ich bin 1,73 Meter.
1,73 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ja, so ungefähr 2.
Frau Helingkötter.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 11. März 1983.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
68 Kilo.
Okay, schon bald.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. April 1967.
14. April 1967.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, das steht immer im Pass drin.
1,77 Meter bin ich.
1,77 Meter, okay.
1,77 Meter, ja?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 79 Kilo.
79, okay.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist Dr. Breitner.
Breitner.
Okay, Breitner. Mit E?
E, R am Ende.
Herr Schubert, was für Sie heute sonst?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
38 Jahre alt.
8,5,3.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 25. Januar 1987.
7,8.
Können Sie bitte weiter schpannen?
Am 25. Januar 1985.
Januar 1985.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Die groß, wozu ist das jetzt wichtig?
Warum brauchen Sie meine Größe?
Ja, da.
Ja, das ist das.
Ja.
Warum brauchen Sie meine Größe?
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist eine Routine-Masagaprage
für das Gespräch.
Ach so.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Ich bin 1,72 Meter.
Und Sie wollen sicherlich auch wissen,
wie schwer ich bin?
Ja.